>> All right Michael, you got the answer?
>> I'm still carrying some squareds.
>> You want to talk it through?
>> Okay. Sure. So, x is really x1x2 and y is
really y1y2 and phi x is now this crazy triple x so I, so I
wrote x1 squared x2 squared, square root of 2x 1x 2.
>> Yeah.
>> That's the vector that we get for phi x.
Then for phi y, I get y1, it seems like it would be helpful to see this.
>> You want me to right it down?
>> Sure.
>> Okay. So that turns out to be the same as
what did you say? x1 squared, x2 squared.
>> Root 2, x1, x2.
>> Root 2, x1, x2. Okay.
>> And then the y vector
gets transformed to the same thing, except for with ys,
y1 squared comma, y2 squared comma, root 2, y1, y2.
>> Okay.
>> So, then, the, the dot product is just, the, the products
of the corresponding components summed up. So x1 squared, y1 squared plus,
>> Okay
>> X2 squared, y2 squared,
>> Mm-hm
>> 2
x1, x2, y1, y2
>> That's right. So here's a question for you, Michael. Does
that look familiar? Based on your years of thinking about algebra.
>> Oh, thanks for writing it that way! I see. We
can, is this right? So it's, it's like, we can factor this.
>> Mm-hm.
>> It's like x1 plus
x2 times y1 plus y2.
>> Yeah, that's right. Wait, is that right?
>> No it's not right. X1 Y1
>> Mm-hm.
>> Plus X2 Y2. Whole thing's squared.
>> Right. So, let's right that down. So if you factor it out, you're right,
this is exactly equal to, X1 Y1 plus X2
Y2. Squared. And what's an even simpler way of writing that?
>> I see. x1 y1 plus x2
y2 looks like a dot product itself. It looks like the dot product of x and y.
Oh, it's x transpose y on the inside, and then we square it on the outside.
>> That's exactly right.
So now do you see why there was method
to my madness when I created the phi function?
>> Not yet. So you're saying, if we're just dealing with
dot products, now I'm still a little confused. So, so it is
the case, that you define these in an interesting way, so
that the dot product became the square of the old dot product.
>> Right, so now let me make two
observations. Okay. Here's observation one. What's x transpose y?
I mean geometrically, what does that represent?
>> The length of the projection of y onto x.
>> No I mean geometrically, like go
all the way back to geometry, third grade.
>> We didn't do transposes in third grade. [LAUGH]
>> I know we didn't do transposes, but you did equations
like this, or at least later you learned they were equations
like this. Here, pretend you're in third grade, and I said
talk to me about geometry. What kind of words would you use?
>> Oh,
what's in geometry? Triangles. Circles.
>> Yeah. Circles! Did you say circles?
>> Sure, but only because I thought you might have wanted me to.
>> Did you say circles?
>> That's a really ugly looking circle, sure.
>> Sure. This is basically a particular form of the equation for a circle
Which means that we've gone from thinking
about the linear relationship between Xi and
Xj or your data points and we've now turned it
into something that looks a lot more like a circle.
>> Interesting.
>> So if and this is my second point, Michael. If you believe
me in the beginning where we notice that Xi transpose Xj is really about
similarity. It's really about why it is you would say two points are close
to one another or far apart from one another. By coming into this transformation
over here, where we basically represented the equation for a
circle, we have now replaced our notion of similarity from
being this very simple projection to being the notion of
similarity is whether you fall in or out of a circle.
>> So more sort of about the
distance as opposed to what direction you're pointing.
>> Right, and both of them are fine
because both of them represent some notion of similarity,
some notion of distance in some space. In the
original case, we're talking about two points that are lined
up together. And over here together with this particular equation
we represented whether they're inside the radius of a circle
or outside the radius of a circle. Now this
particular example assumes that the circle is centered at the
origin and so on and so forth, but the idea
I want you to see is that we could transform
all of our data so that we separated
points from within one circle to points that
are outside of the circle. And then, if
we do that, projecting from two dimensions here
into three dimensions, we've basically taken all of
the pluses and moved them up and all
of the minuses and moved them back, and
now we can separate them with the hyperplane.
>> Without knowing which ones are the pluses
and which ones are the minuses, of course.
>> Of course.
>> Because, I see, because they are the ones that were closer to the origin.
>> Right.
>> So they get raised up less. Wow. Okay. So using that third dimension.
>> Right. Now, this is a cute trick, right? I can basically
take my data, and I transform it into a higher dimensional space,
where suddenly I'm now able to separate it linearly. That's very cute,
but I chose this particular form for a reason. Can you guess why?
>> Because it fits
the circle pattern that you wanted.
>> But there are lots of different ways we
could have fit the circle pattern. I chose this
particular form because not only does it fit the
circle pattern, but it doesn't require that I do this
particular transformation. Rather than taking all of my data
points and projecting them up into three dimensions directly,
I can instead still simply compute the dot product
and now I take that answer and I square it.
>> So you're saying
in this formulation of the quadratic program that
you have there in terms of capital W
if you write code to do that, each time in the code you want to compute that
x1 err Xi transpose times Xj, if you
just squared it right before you actually used
it, it would be as if you projected
it into this third dimension and found a plane?
>> Yes, that's exactly right.
>> That's crazy.
>> It's so crazy it has a name. And that
is the kernel trick. So, again
if we really push on this notion of similarity. What we're really saying is
we care about maximizing some function that depends highly upon
how different data points are alike, or
how they are different. And simply by writing
it this particular way, all we're saying is, you know what, we think the inner
product is how we should define similarity. But instead,
we could use a different function altogether, phi or more
nicely represented as x transpose y squared, and say, that's
our notion of similarity. And we can substitute it accordingly.
>> So we never really used phi.
>> We never used phi. We're able to avoid all of that by
coming up with a clever representation of
similarity. That just so happened to represent
something, or could represent something in a higher dimensional space.
>> So is it important that such a phi exists?
Or is it just the case that we can, you
know, we could, we could throw in a cubed, we
could throw in a fourth, we could do a square
root and a log, like can we do anything we
want there in that Xi transpose Xj? Or are we
constrained to only use things that somewhere out there, there
is a way of representing it as a regular dot product?
>> Well, that is an interesting question. The answer
is you can't just use anything, but in practice it turns out
you can use almost anything. And the other answer to your question
is, it turns out for any function that you use, there is
some transformation into some dimensional space,
higher dimensional space, that is equivalent.
>> Whoa.
>> Now, it may turn out that you need an infinite number of dimensions
to represent it. But there is some
way of transform, transforming your points into higher
dimensional space that happens to represent this
kernel, or whatever kernel you choose to use.
>> So, which part is the kernel?
>> So, the kernel is the function itself. So, in
fact, let me, let me, let me clean up this
screen a little bit. And, and see if we can
make this a little bit more precise and easier to understand.